[Music]
you
my name is wendy baxter and i have
probably one of the coolest jobs on the
planet i get to climb in and study giant
sequoia trees
my name is Anthony Ambrose and I am a
canopy biologist I loved trees and
climbing trees my entire life the first
time I actually climbed a giant sequoia
was just life-changing
there's no branches down low and you're
just climbing up this massive orange
trunk
Anthony is actually the person who
taught me to climb his enthusiasm and
love for these trees is contagious
[Music]
the trees themselves are just enormous I
mean it's almost hard to understand how
big they are
[Music]
it's really quite a long climb so you
get to the top sometimes it's hard to
believe it like what I'm still going
where is the top of this thing just
seems like they're never-ending you get
into the branches and limbs and you get
to see how really big and gnarly and
complex it is it almost feels like I'm
in multiple trees because it has all of
these trunks coming up almost kind of
like a hand
[Music]
you
as you reach the top of the tree you
break out into the light it's just
almost kind of like experiencing you
know sunrise
it is definitely a magical mystical
place you'll also start really getting a
sense of the scale and perspective that
you can only get from being up in the
crown of one of these massive trees
I am climbing on this this living
organism something that is much bigger
and older than I am that I need to
respect
[Music]
they're just so big and you're so small
[Music]
you